I expect you to be married soon are you
in love right now yeah you are
like like yeah I mean the answer is yes
will you propose absolutely
when I can't [ __ ] wait really yeah I
don't know big oh yeah I want to be like
sort of somewhat reasonable about it but
I think like good things happen fast and
yeah propose yeah it's been a yeah yeah
I mean like look this way will you get
down on one knee and traditional
proposition no I can't say right now
because she'll find out have you told
her you want to marry her mm-hmm you
have I also know exact I have a couple
plans that are like the just the coolest
things to do that like I don't think
it'd be is pretty undeniable I'm I'm
really impulsive like I don't know when
that's gonna be but the first time I
told her that I loved her we were like
sitting in this random bar I had only
been like I hadn't had like I've known
her for like six years but we started
like seeing each other it was like two
weeks in but it was like it was
literally like the day that I met her it
was like all bets were off I mean you
were friends for a while like I met her
years ago on a movie and I hadn't seen
her in six years and then she like
rocked up at a friend's birthday party
and I was like where have you been and
how have I not known you she's been like
living in LA alongside my life somehow
but not ever converging and so yeah the
first time I told her I loved her I was
just like it was like really late and we
were in some like shitty bar and her
friends were there or whatever and they
like walked out and I was just like oh
man I'm so [ __ ] in love with you like
done just like that and yeah yeah it
wasn't like a thing and it also it was
like so obvious like it just yeah it's
sick I'm sure that that's how it'll
happen although I do have like a really
good idea we're both from LA and we like
really loved LA and we're both kind of
like scumbags like we both felt like
trolls as kids we're like so similar but
different she's a writer just brilliant
like but I have this like really cool
thing that I'm gonna do that I want to
tell you but I just can't
you